yeah those are such unsettling images
and i was struck by the
by the by what the words that one man
said when he went into the chamber while
we're here we might as well set up a
government
there's a lot of confusion and a lot of
anger in in those images i was struck by
someone saying let's show some respect
when their
their mayor presence is the ultimate in
disrespect when you consider how they
got in and what they were doing
when they were there there's certainly
more to come on that former homeland
security secretary that's jay johnson
joins us
he served under former president barack
obama good morning to you secretary
johnson i want to start with that video
because i'm very curious
about what you thought when you were
watching it i mean it's it's chilling
it's terrifying
we all saw it in real time and thought
it was bad but when you hear what these
rioters were saying
and what they were planning and the
destruction and and
how organized parts of it seemed to be i
want to get your thoughts on that first
[Applause]
gail the images the videos are shocking
i have to say it is something that
hopefully we plan for
we try to anticipate but it's something
that i never thought i would see
in my lifetime i have to say probably
the most shocking
image to me was someone parading a
confederate flag
through the u.s capitol we fought an
entire civil war
to prevent exactly that from from
happening this was
a major major breach of security that
should have been anticipated and could
have been avoided
and now when you look at the uh scenes
at the capitol right now the the
military force that is there
more troops on the ground there than we
have in iraq afghanistan and syria
combined
when you think about that what do you
think is the biggest threat right now
what are we missing
gail four years ago as secretary of
homeland security i had overall
responsibility
for the security of the inauguration of
president trump something like that is
considered an
nsse a national special security event
the secret service takes over they have
overall
charge of the security of the event
they're part of dhs
they work in consultation with the local
metro police
the fbi the coast guard fema homeland
security investigations
and and the national guard and they
literally go through a checklist
of things to make the event impenetrable
from land sea and air it's a massive
security event
it takes months in the planning like a
papal visit or a u.n general assembly
session with world leaders converging on
manhattan
this will be i'm sure the most
security laden inauguration we've seen
probably in my
in my lifetime so do you feel confident
i know you know a lot of people and i
know you know how this job works do you
feel confident that
america will be safe on wednesday
morning a lot of people still
very nervous
gail given the threat picture out there
right now given the
unrest much of it frankly stirred by our
outgoing
president i don't believe we can afford
to be confident i think we have to be
careful
i think we have to be vigilant but
i do have confidence in the skill and
the preparation
of our law enforcement our security uh
forces out there
but we do have to be vigilant and be
extraordinarily careful
given the current threat picture you
know the thing that strikes me more than
anything secretary johnson we're we're
not protecting ourselves against
foreign outsiders we are protecting
ourselves against
fellow americans that's something i'm
still trying to wrap my brain around
how do we do that how do you protect and
now
you know they're even vetting the law
enforcement that's on the ground they're
worried about
some insiders who could ill infiltrate
on that particular day
how do you protect yourselves against
yourself
uh good question gail first and foremost
law enforcement uh efforts at what we
refer to
as countering violent extremism here at
home that is something that
we began to focus on in the obama
administration
through grants through a lot of time and
attention
i spent a lot of time and attention
personally on
our cve issue and it's something frankly
that went off the rails in the last four
years during the trump administration
we need to rededicate our focus
our homeland security threat picture has
evolved dramatically as you note
years after 9 11 we were focused on
foreign-based
violent extremism foreign-based
terrorism
now the principal threat comes from
within yeah and that's very true you
said cde what is that i don't know what
that is cde
cbe countering violent extremism sorry
an acronym
okay yes i know you have to help all of
us lay people out with all that lingo
on this martin luther king on this
martin luther king holiday
you know he famously said the time is
always right to do the right thing
so i'm wondering as you sit here today
what is the right thing
and how are you feeling on this martin
luther king junior day holiday
gail i'm a graduate of morehouse college
class of 1979
dr king was morehouse college 1948.
i went to college with his son he's one
of my best friends
i marched for a holiday in georgia in
the state of georgia while i was a
college student
one of the many things dr king said
which i think of today is that we are
all part of a
single garment of destiny uh in an
inescapable
inescapable network of of mutuality i
think it's time that we in this country
rededicate that uh rededicate ourselves
to that principle i'm hoping that we
hear some of that from
president biden on wednesday in his
inaugural address yes i
i think we all need a reminder a little
primer course or two thank you very much
secretary johnson good to see you thank
you